[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro de sept huit
sociétés votre rendez vous hebdomadaire
on discute des bas des sujets qui font
l'actualité
le pass culture le passeport page
jeunesse ou encore passeport seniors
chaque collectivité propose des aides
financières ou des réductions alors à
qui s'adresse-t-il pourquoi les communes
les départements et le gouvernement les
mettre en place on en parle avec nos
invités béatrice piron bonsoir soit vous
êtes député de la 3e circonscription des
yvelines et membre de la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation
sophie martin bon soit un sort cette
adjointe au maire déléguée aux
associations au sport à la culture et à
la jeunesse de la commune de saint cyr
l'école et en visio ce soir véronique
milot bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes adjointe
au maire déléguée aux seniors à maurepas
et eric de la foi bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes sous directeur culture et promotion
du département des yvelines alors après
deux ans d'expérimentation le
gouvernement ouvre le pass culture à
tous les jeunes de 18 ans béatrice piron
impasse qui offre 300 euros à chaque
jeune oui tout à fait donc c'était d'un
programme présidentiel en 2017 donc qui
était annoncée donc 500 euros pour tous
les jeunes à 18 ans il a été expérimenté
dans divers départements depuis 2018 et
depuis cette année donc le le process a
été adapté à l'expérience qui est effet
t on
les jeunes obtiennent donc 200 euros
quand ils sont adolescents et 300 euros
quand ils sont majeurs ils peuvent les
dépenses et sur deux ans et donc depuis
cette année tous les jeunes qui ont fait
18 ans donc ont reçu 300 euros sur leur
pass culture donc est une application
internet et progressivement donc ça va
être mis en place à partir de la 4e 25
euros 4e 3e 50 euros seconde première
terminale c'est un expérimentation pour
l'instant dans deux collèges et lycées
des yvelines et ça sera généralisé petit
à petit et on passe qui permet d'acheter
des livres de voix d'aller voir des
spectacles
alors ce pass permet aux jeunes de
financer quelques opérations de culture
et donc il est accessible quels que
soient les revenus du jeune donc tout le
monde ya droit et ça peut être consacrés
soit acheté des places de théâtre des
spectacles vivants de la musique des
livres mais également aussi de
s'inscrire pour prendre des cours des
activités donc qui sont en relation avec
la culture par exemple des cours de
danse des cours de théâtre des cours de
musique et donc il ya de multiples
façons de consommer son pass culture
eric de la fois le département des
violences en 2020 le passe plus un
porte-monnaie virtuel de 80 euros et 100
euros pour les boursiers
et une bonne date en mars 2020 dans la
foulée notre partenaire les
hauts-de-seine qui ont qui avait lancé
ce dispositif où on a souhaité
donner une portée interdépartemental à
ce dispositif là qui concerne à peu près
300 mille jeunes potentiels dans les
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine et qui
est aujourd'hui après une année kovy
d'air un peu difficile est en train de
prendre un vrai essor dans les yvelines
et de rattraper le niveau on l'espère
d'ici la fin de l'année d autres 16
alors associé à saint cyr les codes
pardon le pass et jeunesse il est pour
les moins de 25 ans est valable deux ans
oui en fait on a lepage jeunesse pour
les 3 à 25 ans effectivement donc ça
permet une réduction de 50% sur le prix
enfin les entrées de cinéma théâtre et
piscine donc ça quand même un super beau
succès et ça a été créé en 2015 on fait
un petit tour des lieux de ce qui se
fait sur les communes ou les
collectivités de nos invités à maurepas
il ya bien sûr un pass pour les jeunes
mais en 2017 la commune fait le choix de
mettre en place un pass senior véronique
milot il s'adresse aux plus de 62 ans
pourquoi ce choix tout à fait puisque
sur la commune de maurepas on a plus de
20% de la population qui est l'âge
seniors donc d'où ce choix de mettre en
place dans une oeuvre privilégié pour
nos seniors se passe donc d'un accès
donc à des ateliers type ateliers de
prévention qui concerne ma mémoire
l'activité physique le numérique ça
donne voit également son cadet et tarifs
privilégiés donc sur notre cinéma de
proximité 17 mar ou encore va sur notre
offre culturelle représentations sur
l'espace albert camus je vous propose
maintenant qu'on s'intéresse au palms et
le passeport loisirs manie quoi la
commune a fait le choix d'un passeport à
vocation sociale depuis 2016 et les
enfants peuvent être aidés sous
conditions de ressources regard des
scènes de rentrée ordinaire
l'inscription aux activités extra
scolaires les enfants de sougueur fond
du badminton cette année particularité
une partie est prise en charge par la
mairie la famille bénéficier du pass for
many quoi grâce à palm palm j'ai
bénéficié d'économie beaucoup
d'économies pour profiter à mes enfants
et
une autre activité aussi avec le palm
c'est ça fait 45 euros et sans palme
c'est
3-4-3 plus comme je me sport surtout le
montage pourrait en faire plus que ce
que j'en fait par exemple on a fait
désirer je pense qu'on va faire
peut-être quatre heures par semaine en
fait elle la commune conclu des
partenariats avec vingt et une
associations 2020 manille badminton
accueille entre 10 et 15% de palme s'il
n'ya pas le palu ne peuvent pas venir
c'est quand vous avez deux ou trois
enfants avec l'inscription est à 100
balles qui encore on est on est en
on est un club très cher juste les
enfants peuvent pas le faire socialement
je trouve que c'est important pour eux
de pouvoir partager aussi avec leurs
copains d'école de venir en club le palm
existe depuis 2016 le passeport est
aujourd'hui accessible de la maternelle
à la première année de lycée sous
conditions de ressources quotient
familial de moins de 10000 euros la
population qui n'ont vraiment pas
beaucoup de ressources échappe
totalement à la aux associations et aux
activités pour les enfants et c'est donc
que nous avons réfléchi à tout ça nous
avons décidé non pas de donner 40 euros
60 euros pour une inscription à une
association mais de prendre en charge
l'inscription total à l'exception de 15
ou 30 ans ou 50 euros 30 euros tour
alors c'est 30 et 50 maintenant ça a
changé en 2016 70 palm avait été
demandée pour cette rentrée ce sont plus
de 300 bénéficiaires dénombrés par la
mairie de magny les hameaux
alors ce dispositif est accessible à la
condition aussi de bénéficier d'une aide
supplémentaire notamment le pass plus
mais aussi le passeport battre
espérons-le ce fameux passeport il a été
créé ce mois-ci fin il est disponible
depuis ce mois ci une dette de 50 euros
par enfant pour financer une activité
sportive oui donc normalement les
familles donc qu'ils touchent sur
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire ont
reçu pendant le mois d'août ou début
septembre un courrier monkey man et plus
ou moins de la caisse d'allocations
familiales qui indiquait donc les
enfants qui pouvaient bénéficier de ce
passeport de 50 euros qui vient ce donc
s'additionner a parfois des aides qui
peuvent être de haut niveau de la
commune ou au niveau du département
parce que l'objectif est effectivement
que tous les jeunes puissent reprendre
une activité sportive beaucoup en ont
été privés pour des raisons qu vide
depuis 18 mois il est important à la
fois pour les jeunes qu'ils fassent du
sport et qui prennent l'habitude de
faire du sport dès le plus jeune âge
mais aussi pour les associations
donc on avait déjà remarqué l'année
dernière il y avait une baisse des
inscriptions au niveau des associations
certaines associations peut être en
difficulté s'est elle passe en dessous
d'un certain seuil de nombre d'adhérents
est donc pour pouvoir relancer et
remettre un avant le sport pour tous il
a été décidé d'aider les familles à
inscrire les enfants alors le sport sera
aussi au coeur du passe plus eric de la
foi est-ce que aussi on l'a entendu
c'est des choses dont les jeunes ont pu
être privés depuis cette crise
finalement de lancer en mars de vie 2020
il donne peut-être un autre regard à se
passe plus notre importance
aujourd'hui donc le pass plus s'adresse
aux jeunes dès l'entrée en 6ème jusqu'à
jusqu'à la majorité qu'ils soient
domiciliés ou scolarisés dans les
yvelines et les hauts-de-seine aussi
puisque nos de collecte des eaux seine
met le mettre en place c'est exactement
le même constat qu'ont affaires de chute
adhérents dans les associations
sportives et culturelles est un des
objectifs majeurs du pass plus pour nous
c'est que les jeunes s'inscrivent dans
des activités tout au long de l'année
donc cette logique d'abonnement sur ce
acceptable à est très importante et que
aujourd'hui en termes de consommation de
notre passe plus on a une grande
prédominance du sport qui qui est à
l'origine de 80% des dépenses liées aux
passes plus chez les jeunes avec avec
20% uniquement sur la culture mais on
essaye de
davantage équilibré cet état de fait et
cette équipe passe par la communication
sur et autour de ce dispositif puisque
aujourd'hui nous avons 1200 structures
affiliées et que on continue nos efforts
de communication et de prospection pour
ouvrir le davantage de choix aux jeunes
pour qu'ils découvrent aussi de
nouvelles activités donc c'est vraiment
pour à la fois ouvrir les jeunes ont
alors donné une direct et aussi pour
soutenir les associations comme madame
la députée elle a dit effectivement il
ya des business models qui était
vraiment agi gizeh et qui ont besoin de
ces dispositifs là aussi pour
pour assurer la survie de l'association
et la pérennité de l'activité
lors de notre reportage à manier les
mots nos différents interlocuteurs nous
ont dit que bien sûr c'est parce
permettent d'accéder à des activités
mais ils ont aussi un rôle de vie en
collectivité sophie marvaud est ce que
le pass jeunes de la ville de saint cyr
écoles
favorise sa suce que finalement le
cinéma à la piscine et le théâtre s'ils
sont des moments de vie en collectivité
tout à fait c'est un fort succès parce
qu on a pu noter une progression en fait
des entrées par rapport au cinéma au
théâtre et à la piscine donc on fait
certaines familles peut-être sans cette
réduction de 50% ne pourrait pas se
permettre de faire ce genre de sortie
est-ce que vous devez aller aussi auprès
de vos bénéficiaires est ce que tous les
sens syrien savent alors en fait si au
calme relativement bien communiquer au
niveau du site de la ville nous avons
aussi un guide et nous avons aussi un
petit plus pour les familles qui ont
fait calculer leur quotient familial
elles peuvent bénéficier de chèques
associatif donc ça permet aussi aux
enfants de pouvoir s'inscrire à des
activités culturelles ou sportives donc
elles peuvent bénéficier d'un chèque qui
peut aller de 40 à 120 euros et pour en
fait ça reste pour les jeunes de 3 à 17
ans et pour les jeunes de 11 à 17 ans
moins de 17 ans on va dire là ça va être
un chèque unique en 2 30 euros et ça
c'est lié au quotient familial qui est
calculé cette voie là c'est ça nous a
fait un choc tout est cumulable
véronique millions à maurepas quelle est
la place du passeport seniors est ce que
les mort pas un de plus de 62 ans on
bénéficie beaucoup
de talent gré on allait plus de 1000
seniors 1 qui bénéficient de ce
passeport l'idée effectivement le
proposer à cette tranche d'âge face à
éviter l' isolement parce qu'une fois
qu'ils adhèrent au passeport ils
reçoivent à toutes les informations les
activités qui seront proposées par la
ville la plupart voilà gratuites ou à
des tarifs préférentiels s'est vraiment
mis en place aussi bas dans le but
d'éviter isolement de favoriser le lien
social que les seniors se rencontrer
notamment des thés dansants
c'est dans ce support aussi qu'ils ont
toutes les dates voilà deux rencontres
de grands événements de repas
dont celui de lien social et qui trouve
toute sa place dans notre ville et les
seniors i se montrait très attaché oui
c'est plus le lien social que les
bénéficiaires viennent chercher
oui et puis voilà des activités aussi
qu'ils en sont vraiment dédié et
adaptées notamment pas mal d'ateliers
prévention qui sont mis en place en lien
avec le prij prévention en retraite ile
de france donc voilà les seniors à lyon
c'est gratuit pour eux et puis voilà qui
est à comment une plus-value lorsqu'il
faisait partie s'ils font là on à l'exit
attentes
c'est vraiment retrait dans l'est alors
chaque semaine nous interrogeons nos
téléspectateurs sur une question bien
sûr en lien avec le thème de l'émission
pour ce numéro s'était sorties loisirs
activités avez vous souscrit à des
cartes d'abonnement on va le voir c'est
le nom qui l'emportent alors je
demandais à chaque invité celui qui
souhaite répond est-ce que c'est parfois
aussi peut-être un manque de
communication une méconnaissance pour
ceux qui pourraient en bénéficier
madame piron alors c'est difficile de
communiquer en ses forces tout ça vous
rend si vous jouez un rôle important
dans le rôle de la communication dans
les yvelines et tout le monde je pense
que la mairie de saint cyr l'école les
mairies lors des forums des associations
ont mis des affiches ont communiqué
là-dessus sur les panneaux des villes
dont là on a eu quelques exemples de
quelques villes mais beaucoup de villes
font ça s'appelle parfois des bons de
réduction par exemple pour les familles
nombreuses moi j'ai dans ma
circonscription à bailly noisy des
possibilités d'avoir soit des forfaits
en euros soit des 20 % de réduction pour
les familles de plus de trois enfants
par exemple pour les activités sportives
on essaie de communiquer au maximum moi
par exemple j'ai communiqué lors des
forums des associations de ma
circonscription auprès des associations
pour que les associations soient elles
même informé parce que des fois il ya
une petite démarche à faire notamment
pour les clubs sportifs pour pouvoir se
faire enregistrer ou pour même le pass
yvelines pour se faire enregistrer ou le
pass culture donc la démarche n'est pas
toujours facile et simple il est
important donc de leur de les aider dans
cette démarche et puis qui puisse dire à
tout le monde tous les candidats toutes
les personnes intéressées que
normalement il faut pas qu'il ya un
frein financier si un jeune veut faire
du sport ou si un jeune veut faire une
activité culturelle s'il a très envie il
faut essayer de trouver le bon le bon
moyen pour financer au moins une partie
de cette activité et éviter que les gens
sont réfrène pour des raisons
financières monsieur de la fois je vous
ai vu à quai c'est c'est aussi dur de
communiqué
oui alors ben nous on en pleine campagne
de communication où on va sur les canaux
de communication nos cibles parce qu'on
a plutôt une cible collégiens et une
cible jeune pour le pass plus que nos
jeunes c'est 15 18 pour nous et
collégiens avant et on est sur instagram
en ce moment on est sûr tik tok on
essaye d'aller vers eux et c'est vrai
que je vous donnais un chiffre de 42
mille jeunes bénéficiaires inscrits il
ya dix jours on a fait le point ce matin
on est à 45000 donc on voit avec aussi
tout ce travail de forum des
associations on est en pétales de
recrutement donc on ait eu un effet
levier mais il faut vraiment aller sur
sur leurs réseaux et surtout au niveau
des structures ce que nous on appelle
les affiliés donc les théâtres les
associations les clubs sportifs de faire
de l'évangélisme autour de ces
dispositifs la et parfois de se poser la
question et de d'essayer de leur dire la
différence entre les passes parce que
eux-mêmes les côtés organismes s'y
perdent et parfois entre les différents
parce qu'on a un travail de pédagogie à
faire mais plus il ya d'organismes
affiliés plus il ya une offre disponible
donc plus il ya une demande de petits
peut s'identifier à une offre à une
offre claire donc oui ce travail de
communication le on le fait on sait
départemental à la fois dans les
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine puisqu'en
communiquent ensemble sur ce dispositif
et ce fils martin j'imagine que le forum
des associations est fondamental pour
les pages jaunes est complètement donc
c'est vraiment à plus donc c'est vrai
que toutes les associations sont au
courant des différents z donc
communiquer dessus et le petit plus
cette année en l'échec associatifs ont
été envoyées directement par courrier
différentes femmes seulement fallait aux
bénéficiaires mais aller le récupérer
alan alda suivante donc là c'est un gain
de temps au moins ils ont leurs chèques
associatif avant et ça leur permet de
pouvoir s'inscrire auprès des
associations directement vers 9 millions
à mort pas comment vous faites ce que
forum des associations les anciens nos
seniors ne vont pas nécessairement sur
ce lieu de rendez vous vous faites ça
lors des repas des anciens comment ça se
passe alors on était présents cette
année pour la première fois sur le forum
des associations on a eu quelques
inscriptions et c'est vrai que voilà on
communique que les habitent ce public
bleus sur des supports traditionnels
comme le magazine municipal ou voilà on
a également donc un fichier qui recense
pas mal de seniors sur la ville il
apprécie beaucoup haussier de bouche à
oreille puisque le seigneur m'a pas
beaucoup entre eux donc voila mais en
général où elle est la communication se
fait quand même relativement bien sûr la
ville n'a pas mal d'adhésion comme je
vous ai dit en plus plus de 1000 donc et
c'est en augmentation constante tous les
ans alors sur ce pass senior moody's ils
peuvent aller à des bals dansants se
sont beaucoup de rendez vous il ya même
des formations à des premiers secours de
la prévention est-ce que vous avez
parfois aussi de demande plus
surprenante de la part des bénéficiaires
qui souhaiteraient d'autres activités
pour l'instant on n'a pas eu la demande
de demandes supplémentaires
après on assurera notre huysman rappelle
le conseil des aînés donc peut-être que
allocation effectivement on les fera
réfléchir sur d'autres activités qui le
souhaiteraient il ya également ce qui
fait partir le passeport signant ce des
voyages vous propose
organisé donc à la ville pour
l'animation seigneur donc c'est plutôt
sur ce type de d'activités qu'on les
fait réfléchir qu'elle ait exprimé sous
le sceau film harvey milk et 50% sur ses
trois sites de la commune est ce que ça
pourrait amener à être développée sur
d'autres choses dans peut-être des
commerces pour de la ville est ce que
c'est en réflexion pour le moment en
fait ça fait pas partie de ma délégation
donc c'est vrai que plus axé sur le
sport les associations et la jeunesse et
la culture on va dire donc pour le
commerce ça pourrait être l'objet d'une
peut-être la jeune âge et sports en
converse qui seraient seraient seuls
visés savons vraiment des élus dédié qui
cherche à développer les différents
commerces donc pour ça pourquoi pas mais
moi je peux pas me prononcer à leur
place ou à la place de sonia moureaux
qui est notre mère nous rapprochons
modem voilà
eric de la fois au niveau du département
sur les premières associations qui sont
approchés de vous pour se passe plus est
ce qu'il y a des sports en particulier
des activités qui ressorte qui sont plus
intéressés pour faire venir de nouveaux
licenciés
on a un autre top knocked up fine par
leurs activités pour le sport c'est
vraiment le foot qui est très près
dominant le tennis aussi que les traits
qui est très utilisés par les jeunes
pour le passe plus le basket la natation
la gym ça fait partie voilà c'est notre
top 5 en sport que pour la culture c'est
tout ce qui tourne autour de la musique
les conservatoires et les associations
et le théâtre et la danse arrive arrive
juste derrière mais voilà c'est un peu
notre top des tops faille de la culture
et culture et sport top five peut-être
en culture béatrice buiron c'est une
conséquence inattendue notamment du côté
des achats des livres c'est l'explosion
tellement gars on en avait parlé donc au
mois de juillet nous étions sur la
version pour parler de la lecture est
justement de la possibilité d'utiliser
le pass culture pour acheter le livre je
pense que toutes les lectures sont
intéressantes principal que jeunes
aiment lire et prennent du plaisir à
lire donc pourquoi pas les mangas ça
permet aussi d'ouvrir sa culture à des
cultures un petit peu différentes des
nôtres
je connais un petit peu quand même manga
surtout que j'ai vécu moi-même quatre
ans au japon donc c'est un univers qui
j'aime aussi beaucoup mais mais je crois
que c'est bien et justement pour pouvoir
on disait tout à l'heure faire la
promotion de ses passes et de différents
moyens auprès des jeunes je pense que
l'expérimentation à partir de la
quatrième dans les classes avec une
partie du budget qui sera géré en
collectif avec les enseignants donc là
pour l'instant il ya deux co2
établissement le collège tristan à
carrières sous poissy le lycée monnet à
la queue des yvelines donc où les jeunes
vont être un petit peu driver ou coacher
ou accompagnés par leurs enseignants
pour pouvoir dépenser donc ou s'initier
à une partie de la dépense donc de leur
pass culture avec leurs enseignants et
c'est quelque chose qui permet aussi de
mieux communiquer est ce que tous les
jeunes vont à l'école et me semble je
vous propose qu'on s'arrête sur ces
termes sauf si l'un des invités souhaite
rajouter quelque chose
alors c'est cette société maintenant
terminé merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
parler d'un nouveau sujet de discussion
d'ici là bien sûr prenez soin de vous
[Musique]
je